hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar quality controlling your flow
cytometry data for improved experimental
outcomes i'm susie valdez of labyrinth
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bd biosciences to learn more
visit them at bdbiosciences.com
now i want to encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
enrico luiz
a principal investigator and the head of
laboratory of translational immunology
in the flow cytometry core and bob
balderas a distinguished fellow in the
nvp biological sciences and vp market
development at bd biosciences welcome
enrico and bob
may now begin
thank you very much
so hello everyone and uh first of all
thank you very much for for attending
today it's
always a pleasure to to have an
opportunity to to address flow cytometry
you know over over the last year or so
we've had a host we've hosted a number
of domain experts to help us address
you know the many issues and challenges
that we all experience in in building
and working with building panels and
working in flow cytometry
and and that goes beyond just the panel
it goes on to
determining where you get information
about antigen density
it it talks about
you know preparing a sample
how we set up our instruments
all those questions that
come in every single day about
addressing compensation as well as
spectral and mixing and autofluorescence
then when we combine that with what
we've seen over the last just few years
about
moving our flow data and analyzing it
with the new data tools that we have
it gets more and more and more
complicated and the quality of the data
always has to be maintained at the at
the highest level
well today
what we'd like to do is to continue on
this theme
based on the the many inputs and the
questions that just
still continue to come in and they're
shared from scientists like yourself you
know all over the world
we will focus today on on qc of flow
data and how we move that forward
towards you know improving the the
quality of the
interpreted it's my pleasure though
today to introduce dr enrico luli
a distinguished professor and and
certainly a domain expert you know in
the field of flow cytometry
obtained his phd in immunology from the
university of modern and reggio emilia
where he focused his work on t on t cell
immune responses and homeostasis during
the course of hiv infection now it was
at that point in his career that
that he
got a great opportunity and he moved to
the vaccine research center at the nih
where he continued to study the
molecular mechanisms involved in the
maintenance of long-term t-cell immunity
but he was able to do one other thing he
he was with many many different you know
scientists where
the nih is a domain area you know
institution where flow is taught and
where flow is at the top of the list of
the tools that that scientists use and
and thus
how we use it and and that whether it be
the types of instruments that we have
how we look at data and really how they
how they look at the experimentation
it's
it's really really critical
well following that work
that at the nih and and also a
collaboration with thomas waldman he
moved he moved on and obtained an
independent position as the principal
investigator of the laboratory of
translational immunology and his head of
the humanities flow cytometry core
it is my pleasure to
to welcome indorito and enrico you can
uh move forward with your presentation
all right thanks a lot bob um thanks a
lot for the invitation it's a great
pleasure to talk about stuff that is
really
a center of our interest in the lab and
in the flow floor so can you hear me
well um is that
that working okay
can you hear me yeah yeah
okay
okay so um today i want to show you uh
i want to discuss a bit of the things
that we have learned over the years
and i think it's important to know about
them just because
uh we're now advanced the uh technology
data analysis
uh obviously with the work of many
people involved
and uh i i think it's uh it's it's
becoming increasing uh the the
complexity is just increasing uh uh over
and over again
so uh the i i think it's it's important
to discuss what are the the major
caveats that we encounter when we
develop panels and analyze
those uh those data so uh bobby will as
we said i will be nice to chat if you
guys have any questions uh
please interrupt me at any time so if we
i look forward to more more of a chat
and then a like a seminar supposed to be
a a an informal discussion on on flow
so what i want to
go through today is
to discuss some of the major aspects uh
and the major caveats that we
encountered when we developed the
complex panels and uh when we first
approached the analysis of high
dimensional flow system related by using
computational pipelines that i have to
say we're initially developed for
analyzing the type of data or single
cell rna sequencing data then we have
adapted to analyze this effects data
so first of all
probably the basis of what
or what isn't is important here is you
know how to design a panel correctly so
i'm not going through
all the technicalities of panel
development because other people have
done this before me in this platform or
other platforms um
i know yolanda monk a previous colleague
of mine at the nih has done this for
pratik
so in their their great teachers in in
this regard
um
we will touch also the problem with
sample preparation because in some cases
it can lead to
incorrect uh
data collection
uh obviously the tech quality is very
important and we'll see um
pre-processing and change uh
the your your final results follow from
some computational and now this is
something we have published a few years
ago
and finally also something that we tend
to forget is uh obviously the biologist
so the biology is very important and uh
we shouldn't think and we just have
numbers in the matrix we're talking
about cells and expression of proteins
and so we have to look at our data
always in the in in light of the biology
that we study
uh so
uh i think it will it's important to
mention a paper that we have published
in nature protocols a couple of years
ago with uh yolanda bruhmann its first
author and this was done together with
the life of worker baker in zurich
this paper i suggest you to
read it and i'll be happy to welcome
suggestions and critiques
um
and it's it's a
it's a list of
all the procedures that
you could apply to develop apply and
computationally analyze high-dimensional
position
data it has all the all the protocols
they might be
generate your high-dimensional
stuff
so um
here if we start uh from from from the
basics uh so
on the on the top left uh you see for
example a comparison of a couple of
reagents that we have tested and the
suggestion obviously is to use always
the best reagents so sometimes this is
not always possible
um
sometimes this is not always possible
but um
just just to give you an idea of how two
different reagents uh the same clone but
in two different colors they perform
completely different so on the left we
have a c2750 on the right we have c27p
so you can see obviously the p is much
brighter so when you develop a panel
then you should just follow uh you
should just choose the best reagent if
you have that possibility and obviously
some one other thing that we do we test
every single reagent that comes to the
lab so we do a full titration of to
determine the
the the saturating concentration and and
here the arrows tells you what is the
best concentration of which you should
use that reagent uh but sometimes that
can be um
the the the the procedure you use to
prepare your reagents can actually
change the performance of of of the
stain because on the top right you see a
difference
in um
not from the positive signal in this
case of an anti-tissue antibody but
actually uh
of the background that is increasing
very much what you do when you use a
phosphate free fixation pronunciation
procedure so that might be important for
a detecting intracellular antigen but
has a drawback of increasing the
background very much and in that case
you can lose a
sensitivity in that channel so
in that case you don't have very much
possibility unless you change
antibody combination or you
don't do the permeabilization procedure
so another important thing that we
check there carefully especially when we
do experiments in different days and
different batches so obviously want to
avoid a batch effect between different
days is uh to
not have compensation issues so this is
something which is uh that we control
very well
back in the days we we encountered this
this issue even though we're following
the three major rules of compensation uh
the the development but
by mario ritter so so mario obviously
was extremely instrumental in this
regard
um
we even though we were following those
three rules we actually encountered this
problem so for example when when we used
every time we used abv-711 antibodies so
it didn't matter on the recognition of
the antigen it was just the floor from
that i was interested by by this problem
so but you
when we compensate we can use
compensation base and in 99.9 percent of
the cases it works great but in this
case it's actually oh it was always
associated with over compensation at
least in this combination of these and
video 11 into the apc r 700 channel
um we don't really know the the reason
why but we realized that if we used
cells
to make our own who are our single same
compensation controls instead of the
beats then the compensation was perfect
and on the right you can see that both
comps uh well both single same
compensation controls were bright enough
to to allow you to calculate
compensation but it was just uh
you know the binding of the bees that
was somehow changing uh the interference
and the contribution into into the
secondary channel
so um now we we uh we over uh now we
overcome that by using cells instead of
beats where we need to compensate our uh
our our panels and and then it works uh
it works perfectly and we don't have to
worry about that anymore so but remember
that you might have those those issues
um
so now we uh
so we
know that we talked a bit about the
panel development but again i'm not
going to go into the all the details of
of the panel development now you have to
get your data you acquire your data and
you have to process your data for
computational analysis so here is uh
always from our nature protocol paper um
an an example of uh um
of the
the the removal of the unwanted events
that we want to have uh before
performing computational analysis so you
can see from the slides uh that in some
cases uh we can have some antibody
aggregates so for example in the in the
second row and in the in the central
plot
uh we can have uh just expression of
some spurious events that are very
those events are uh um
those events are not really um
um
they should be excluded from
from the analysis in that case um
i'm sorry having some issues with
control of the slides
so so the the folks that they they they
you can keep control of the slides if
you want
it's fine and then we'll just say next
and you'll move to the next one
okay so sorry sorry for interrupting um
so we we apply a very stringent gating
uh procedure just to select the
population of interest and in this case
uh we can select just the the
the population that is of interest for
us that is dependent on the uh on the
biological fashion so if you're
interested just in the cd8 and that's
something we'll see later in the
presentation then you can just select
the cd8 or otherwise uh if you want to
have the full spectrum of immunity for
example in a tumor
we generally include hd45 antibody and
then we isolate all cd45 positive cells
and and computationally analyze those
but it's important to remove all the
cells that we're not interested in and
all the cells that can be a source of
artifact because if you have spurious
events for example due to antibody
aggregates or or
those they don't generally uh
they generally look under compensated uh
but you shouldn't worry about the
compensation of those because they they
just follow
their their
their own their own
their own rules and so you should you
should remove those and not have them in
your final analysis and you can export
uh all those files and then feed them
into your favorite r script and we're
going to talk about that um
in a second
um
so how the when we
developed this this nature protocols
paper with border baker we also wanted
to include the part and how to qc your
data before feeding them into your uh
computational analysis so but that's
important because
in the past we used to go through every
single file every single uh uh every
single sample uh for example by by using
our favorite uh flow cytometry analysis
software so now we we tend not to do
that anymore because otherwise it would
be like a huge waste of time so
obviously we check that everything is
fine in terms of quality of the data but
we don't really check for for the the
position of of every single population
that should be done by by doing a strong
and and very uh defined uh qc on on your
machine or on your panel development um
so if you go to the next slide slide
number seven
um
so in slide number seven here you see
that uh in this case we ran three
different uh samples one from a healthy
donor one from a cancer patient from the
peripheral blood and and from the tumor
of of the patient and we overlaid
all the antigen expression and so in
most of the cases you you don't have uh
like strange patterns uh but i just want
to highlight a couple of examples the
one that is correct and one that isn't
correct it is incorrect and uh yeah you
should uh you know you should ring a
bell when when you see strange things
like that so for example in the case of
cd4 you can see that uh the peak of cd4
expression is exactly in the same place
doesn't matter where it comes from um if
it is from the healthy donor the patient
plot or the patient tumor so this is
important because from the biology we
know that c4 expression on the cell
surface tends to be very stable you have
a fixed
number of receptors on the cell surface
so when you're staying with antibodies
at saturating concentration then you
should see uh fluorescence always in the
same place so obviously you um you see a
different abundance of cd4 expression
because from from the tumor we don't
really have that many is infiltrating
the tumor at least in this case instead
from the peripheral blood or the healthy
donor we have more and many more cd4
but different is uh for example on on
the bottom left uh this gene this
protein called a gnoy or granolysis so
gradualizing is a toxic marker and um
we know from biology that just a
fraction of the cells express
granulism so you should have the
majority of the cells that are negative
and a bit of cells are positive and in
general the expression of the protein is
a smear of fluorescence so if you see
the sample in
in red here uh the patient's blood it
looks like the peak has all moved to the
right so ideally you could think that
all cells are positive but we know that
this is not possible because
gradualizing if you know a little bit
about t cell differentiation
is expressed by terminally
differentiated cytotoxic cells okay they
could be cda cells or c4 cells
and so
it's not possible unless it is a very
strange sample that your
patient's blood has a lot of granolatin
being expressed because there will be
some naive cells for example which are
the very beginning of differentiation
and in that case naive cells by biology
they don't express
they don't express granulism so it's not
possible that we have a signal like that
so this should ring a bell and in that
case um we we have uh
we we have a a strange expression
of a stranger pattern of fluorescence
for that antigen for that specific
sample
so what do we do in that case so in that
case before feeding all the data into
the computational pipeline one thing we
can do is we can just remove that
parameter from analysis
but obviously uh
so this will will compromise the uh the
whole analysis for granulizing otherwise
if you want to keep
this parameter in in the final analysis
then uh you just
remove that specific sample so in this
case you need to find a compromise um
because you can have you can have it all
unless you control for everything but
in some cases it's very difficult so we
don't know what happened in this essay
but we're happy that it happened so we
could give you an example
um
it was probably sample dependent because
one thing we did afterwards we had a
replicate vial
from that individual
we follow the cells and we stained again
and we didn't see that problem anymore
so
there might have been something that
went wrong for
with staining for that specific
patient's blood and we don't really know
the cause it would be great to know the
cause sometimes usually you just notice
you you either repeat your experiment or
or you remove the sample from the
analysis
um
so another thing that we can do is uh we
can
we can analyze uh the antigen expression
this is more
intuitive and it's also dependent on the
experience of the of the researcher but
if you if you look on the right you see
a lot of disney plots and we overlay the
expression of every single antigen and
we just looked at the expression of of
of these antigens was co-regulated or
anti-anti-regulated
depending on on the biology uh so for
example you know the c-39 is almost
never co-expressed with 127
if you know the biology of t cells so
this this is a just a way to show you if
the data follow what you expect
but obviously you don't always think
that you will obtain what you expect
because otherwise you know you will
never discover anything so just just
keep your eyes open also for for the
data looks strange because i i think
it's it's always nice to to follow
what is undefined
um
if we can go to the next slide
so thank you um
here this is something that we um that
we encountered a while ago uh
when we
uh
decided to analyze the samples by by
titans this was
uh one of the first times that we used
the testing to analyze soil cytometry
data in this case we did a an
interesting experiment because we wanted
to test the the
the the
the the possibility to replicate data in
different experiments over time so here
we talk three different lp donors that
we run over pbmcs that we run over five
different experiments it was a 27
parameter panel
we run over five different experiments
in five different days
and we we isolated the cd8 cells in this
case and then we run tis me by using the
parameters that are indicated here and
then we de-barcoded so every sample had
barcodes so we after analysis we could
debarcode and look at the tension
distribution uh over the five different
experiments and what you can see here in
in in these five different experiments
we just uh draw a a a gate that gate
doesn't really identify anything it's
just identify your regions uh but you
can see the percentage of the cells
inside different gates uh was actually
very different so we thought what is
going on here we might have done
something very strange or there is no
reproducibility
uh over um the different um
over the different experiments uh if we
can go to the next slide please
um so we thought about different uh
possible sources of error um
so you might have technical reasons uh
or you might have computational reasons
of why we obtain that uh
non-reproducibility
so first of all we thought about
instrument performance uh that was
unlikely because we checked uh
instruments with rainbow beast every day
we imported the protocol the steep
professor developed at the at the nih
years ago to track your instrument
performance from day to day and we were
pleased to see i don't have the data
here but it's published but uh we were
pleased to see that actually the
performance of the instrument over the
these five experiments spending a few
weeks was actually rock steady so it
didn't really move the instrument was
very stable um
so with the it wasn't the instrument
itself was not a source of error we
thought about the batch effect like
antibody staining or pipette well we
didn't really see any effect because we
didn't really see changes in the
expression of the different proteins
also the the
the staining was was correct
uh obviously compensation we have talked
about compensation before compensation
spreading error um
that we knew is very important when we
developed panels uh was was similar
across the five different experiments uh
but
we realized that background fluorescence
was was different from uh from the
different experiments for some of the
antigens okay so we observe difference
between samples and we realize that if
we um
by exponentially transform or logically
transform the samples before feeding
them into
a computational analysis uh then we
obtained as you can see in this disney
year very good reproducibility from uh
from one uh uh experiment to the other
so you can see that the plots look uh
very much similar from one to the other
um so sometimes you see you see some
some movement cloud
but but this is due to micro differences
in in the mfi from from experiment to
experiment that maybe you want if you
want you can consider to uh
to normalize if you have always the same
sample
the same reference samples run across
the different experiments that you're
you're analyzing
um so these are some of the
difficulties that we encounter when we
first
developed complex panels and and we
wanted to analyze them uh by
computational analysis so i just want to
move uh uh so if there is any questions
uh
coming up i'll be happy to answer
otherwise i'll just go on and uh
and discuss all the um
the display of these high-dimensional
data that we obtained by computational
analysis
yeah
let's
uh we'll save these questions for a
little bit later there's a number of
them okay
okay so let's just keep going so if we
can go to the next slide i'm going to
introduce
different ways we used to display high
dimensional single cell uh single cell
data so if you can go to the next slide
this is a study that we have done uh a
few years ago again yolanda blumen is
first author a great post office that's
daily my life for a few years
um and
when
when
first of all she pioneered the uh the
develop the optimization of this
technology in the lab and then uh used
it to analyze uh the infiltrate of uh
non-small-cell lung cancer samples
this was a collaboration with thoracic
surgery in our institute so she took 53
different tumors in impaired lung
tissues
and at the same time she analyzed 23
different bloods
she processed the single cell suspension
then she analyzed the cd8 cells
um
so
here as i said we didn't do uh standard
gating anymore so we did engage on
on on first on the first two antigens
and then defining the population and
then going down uh with two more
antigens and two more antigens
uh here we decided to take all cd8 cells
from every single individual um just for
for um
just for speed we took three thousand
cells per sample we probably didn't need
that many cells to analyze just just to
have an idea of how the data looked like
um we isolated old cd8 cells we barcoded
them with a unique barcode so
so we could go back and look at every
individual sample and we we
would put them together into a single
huge file and this was was a big file of
many hundreds of thousands of cells that
we analyzed by um the clustering
algorithms and these clustering
algorithms were able to give us a number
of different clusters that we'll see in
a in a second in and these clusters
basically have a certain phenotype that
you can determine um
and you then you can use your favorite
data display method and i'm going to
show you uh two or three of them just to
have an idea of how we show the data so
if we can go to the next slide
this is just a heat map
i'm gonna walk you through this
the heat map shows you the antigen
expression in the different clusters
you've got the markers in in the in the
columns so you can see it's you actually
are five six zero three is the 73 and so
on
uh
and then you've got the phenograph
clusters so we use this computational
algorithm called phenograph developed
initially for a single cell rna
sequencing and you can tune the
parameters to obtain less or more
clusters depending on
on what on on what is your
idea of the data but in this case we had
more than 20 clusters that we obtained
and there is uh uh just just to have a
little bit of granularity on on the data
so now then we made a cluster both the
markets and and the clusters so all the
different markets and different clusters
are are put together according to their
similarities and differences and the
colors indicate the abundance of antigen
expression so in this case we used a
an approach that we imported against
from mario's lab called
integrated mfi which is just the mfi
multiplied by the frequency of positive
cells
this can have
[Music]
this can be this can can have advantages
and disadvantages as any display method
so any display method might have
limits um
but i think it's it's intuitive on one
side and then also indicative of the
protein abundance per cluster okay so
for example imagine having all these
clusters you are able to sort them and
you do single and you do rna sequencing
on all of them and you will have somehow
a similar result so the abundance of
protein expression in this case
or of rna in the case of rna sequencing
pair population and this is more or less
the same thing we're doing here so you
have an idea of the abundance of protein
expression in every single cluster you
identify
so
there is a that might be a disadvantage
so the calculation may be biased by the
frequency of positive cells or the mfi
so for example if you have few cells
with high protein expression or many
cells with low protein expression you
might end up
with the same result so i in the end
these this is great to walk you through
the data to give you an idea of the
trends that you have in in the speed
data but at the same time it's always
great to go back to the raw data and use
your standard methods then to to analyze
the data and confirm uh this is a very
good way to to have a fast idea of what
is going on going on in your huge data
set
as i said in the very beginning so we
barcoded every single individual so we
could then do barcode in the analysis in
this case we just debarcoded into three
different tissues in this case with the
blood the normal tissue and the tumor
and then we by using these balloon
blocks
we display the abundance of every single
cluster and we could do our favorite
statistics to see what was the
difference in the abundance between the
tumor and the blood or or the normal
tissue
so if we can go to the next slide
this is just a different way to show to
show data so it's a different panel but
more or less it
gives you a similar result so instead of
using a heat map here we use a balloon
plot
where the balloons
are the size of the balloon
is indicative of the percentage of
positive cells
and the color is indicative of the mfi
so the bigger the balloon the more cells
so this solves the problem that we had
before
the bigger the balloons the more cell
express
that antigen and uh the more cells yeah
let's express that antigen and and the
darker the color
than the higher the mfi from for that
specific antigen in the different in the
different classes again you can meta
clusters these clusters and and the
antigen as well and by using uh your
knowledge name you can
name all the clusters that you obtain
on the right we have uh just bar charts
depicting the frequency of every single
cluster among the different tissues also
in this case we had a blood tissue or
normal uh tissue in the tumor tissue
this this was from a breast cancer a
paper that an israel published in my lab
uh what is the advantage of this one
of this display
from the rise is that you have an idea
of what is the frequency of a given
cluster across the different tissues but
at the same time has a disadvantage uh
because it doesn't give you uh
a definitive answer on on the abundance
across all the different classes so you
don't know if that uh cluster is
actually rare or or very abundant so
also again uh it can solve some problems
but at the same time you might have
limitations on on other sides so it's
always important to consider all the
different display methods and and
be aware of the limitations that you
might encounter
if we can go to the next slide
um this is the same data from the lung
cancer study in this case we
wanted to depict
the cluster abundance that we obtained
by phenograph clustering in all the
individuals that we analyze
so uh showing individual samples can be
very important um it's important to see
atherogeneity it is important to see
what is
the etherogeneity in your cohort of
individuals and
at the same time see how the different
tissues
look like
if they're similar or not so in this
case for example
we did meta clustering of all these
clusters and we can see that the blood
samples in blue they all cluster into a
branch of the tree and the tumor in the
different branches of the tree inside
the normal tissues are are scattered
between the blood and
between the blood and and the tumor
tissue so some tissues look like more
that you more more uh more like the
tumor and others more like the blood
the other interesting thing you may
identify subgroup subgroups of
individuals uh so in this case you might
think that maybe there might be
estrogenated and maybe some patients uh
are different from others by looking at
the immune phenotype in this case
supposed to see the c80 is called
phenotype as a whole the other important
thing
um by using this method
you don't have aggregate data but you
have data from every single individual
you can see if there is a specific
contribution from one single individual
to the
to to the the identification of a given
population so for example the cluster
that we see in orange uh that you you
just have it in a
very uh specific set of blood samples
but not in all the samples so that means
that the contribution of of that cluster
will be from uh uh two or three
individuals and not throughout the
entire cohort i think that's very
important because it otherwise you might
um
you might be driven by by the wrong data
when you have cumulative data or summary
data in this case you can clearly see
what is the contribution of every single
individual
so finally if we can go to the next
slide i just want to uh talk about the
power of integrating single-side
technologies so that's something that we
have discovered in a recent nature uh
immunology
paper that we published last year
from giovanni galetti and others um
if we can go to the next slide please so
here we have done um
we started in an unbiased way so
the flow cytometry is great on one side
because you can measure
at least and by using the technology we
use up to 30 parameters on single cells
and uh which is not huge which is not uh
small but at the same time it's not huge
but i think it can be
very enlightening
and at the same time you can measure
millions of cells so that's the very
good thing
um
nevertheless there is no technologists
that can measure thousands and thousands
of genes from a single cell such as
single cell rna sequencing many people
use it to use it now so at the time we
thought okay so let's let's have a look
at the peripheral blood c8 positive t
cell compartment if by using this
technology we discover something new
which is not always the same subset
um
so here you have a
um
different clusterization of
of
of
different cell subsets
um
we were interested in self of the
yearly differentiated
compartments which are the clusters at
the top i'm sorry the the animation is
broken here but uh the clusters at the
top identify early differentiated memory
cells
but the important message here is
that we identified uh a protein called
grant k that was differential expressed
between these two clusters and we used
that to design a panel along a number of
other
antigen receptors
to develop a high dimensional flow
cytometry panel if we can go to the next
slide
um
so here
uh
so by using granzan k we were actually
able to distinguish ccr7 positive guns
and k-positive and ground as a
k-negative cell
um the interesting thing is uh by by
including engines that we thought were
probably important for t-cell
differentiation we were able to show
that these grants and k-positive cells
which
in the at the first glance look like
defector cells
uh actually expressed inhibitory
receptors such as digit and pd1 and
that's something that we didn't see by
single cell sequencing and the reason
why i don't know i guess it's because
[Applause]
the expression
in the peripheral blood that the level
of the mrna is low or the other
possibility is that the technology is
not powerful enough to see those in rnas
but when we
use flow to detect protein that we saw a
very good protein expression that you
can see here in this view map if you can
go to the next slide is just the raw
data to show you
that we can have very bright pd1 and
digital expression in the peripheral
blood and on the left you have the naive
control which by biology shouldn't
express these nematode receptors we
found that the the stem-like membrane
cells the population of cells that we i
discovered together with luca gatinoni
when i was a postdoc in in mario's lab
expressed some and central memory cells
where uh
actually the ones expressing the most
so this was the foundation of of of a
new study that
led to the identification of precursors
of exhausted cells which is something
that we have never seen before uh in the
peripheral blood of healthy individuals
and and we studied in the epigenetic and
functional level
so just to wrap up if we can go to the
next slide please
i just want to give you the most
important take on messages uh from uh
from from this uh this webinar and i'm
happy to take questions afterwards so
computational analysis are
great tools that we can use to rapidly
investigate transgender data
okay so we use gating now to confirm the
data according to established
definitions so for example if we
identify cells that look like t-rex then
we can
baptize that cluster as a t-rex but then
we have to go back to the to the raw
days that say
that cd25 positive for speed3 positive
are actually increased or decreased in a
given cohort of individuals
um
the the advantage of these tools is huge
um the effort in time is very different
we can you it takes hours to analyze
huge amount of data so
in generally it takes
let's say a few days to develop a panel
a few days to run
the the samples a few hours to analyze
the data and probably a few weeks to
interpret
the data
i remember when i was a postdoc and i
used to do gating in in dozens of
samples which is not a huge number uh
nowadays and it took me weeks to
to go through the whole study and now
within hours we can get you know an idea
we can have an idea of how the data
looks like but remember there is many
many possible sources better probably
more than than those i have mentioned
here in computational analysis the
machine performance can be it's very
important we qc instruments every day
and before every experiment we do
uh so so that's something that i i will
thank forever steve professor and and
mario did that they taught me how to do
it
um so panel development is a possible
source of error so we have published the
paper in in that sense but there is many
more papers that you can follow uh in
that regard the data preprocessing we
have seen that it can be a source of
error and obviously it's sample and
simple handling which can generate
artifacts
my suggestion is so our major prop
course paper contains uh instructions on
how to use phenograph or or flowsome and
other clustering algorithms developed by
event science in in ghent
but you can use many different pipelines
there's actually now a new pipeline
every week uh so most of these are
developed for single-celled sequencing
or site often they must be optimized for
for to handle fax data it might take a
while but uh but i i guess it's worth
the effort
uh and if you want to explore more uh
what we have done so far
you can get our scripts they're all
available in github and on the lab page
so
also if you want to reach me by email or
on twitter
at lunalab uh you can you can you can
chat with me and i'll be happy to
provide you with with suggestions or
expertise uh if you if you need any help
so the next slide i just wanted to thank
all the people involved in this i
mentioned many times yolanda brumenman
who pioneered the optimization of these
technologies
uh first in in in our lab and uh georgia
lizzie who has been supporting her very
much and uh
the computational biologists in my lab
emilia martin simoni pujo have done a
lot of work in in this sense and all the
collaborators and the funding
so thank you very much thanks bob and
i'm happy to to chat more about this
thanks enrico thank very much i think
you know some of your comments you know
at the end that that you brought in
about
the experience that you had and and got
from mario's lab about making sure that
instrument is like qc'd every day is is
always a
everyone but
you know i think we all know that in
so many labs around the world and core
facilities they're they're wonderful you
know
domain individuals that take care of
these experiments for us all the time
and maintain those instruments at the
highest level and and when they are then
we that we have a greater chance of a
really great success but
enrico we had
you know have a number of questions and
i think for the questions that are
coming in just to let everybody know
if we don't get to them
we will we will address them and we will
get in contact with you and make sure
that that that any very that the
specifics to every question are are
addressed but
we we have uh
maybe you know enrico
we have a number of questions and and i
think you know we can take them from
many different directions but
you know as we go
higher and higher in plexi
you know with the
with the types of technologies that we
have today
and
we we we're faced with with
you know situations like fluorescence
minus one
and
right you know when it's it's doable
right when you when you got 10 15 colors
right to work with and
what do you see
what do you see what should we do as we
as we approach you know
25 and 30 and 35 you know colors and and
maybe
don't have enough cells to really
evaluate that sample from every
direction
right so
uh
so first of all you the fluorescence
minus one controls they're great to see
to define where the positivity for
engine is okay
so the one thing we have to
keep in mind is also
they tell you if uh compensation is
correct so so if you have problems with
compensation for questions minus one
control will tell you if if it's working
or not and obviously the other thing is
if you have a lot of spreading into a
given channel
that might be that might be important
so we tend to do that for uh antigens
that
we don't really know the pattern about
okay so if you have say h la dr
expression h-l-a-d-r is
in constitutes this mirror of expression
so in that case we tend to do
uh we tend to do with as a mode controls
um
but if we have antigens that we know
very well and and
are generally separate very well we
don't develop small controls in that
case
the other important feature i want to
mention because we tend to forget about
this so
uh you you you must be
carefully using so fmo is is the control
where you have all the antigens except
one okay except one antibody
uh
your antibody that you're removing in
the fmo control must be titrated
carefully
because if you add that antibody and
then your background goes higher just
because it's the nature of the antibody
given more background
or in that case
the fmo will be used
so i think that's important to uh to
remember
yeah it's you know it's just a again a
reminder of
you know how you balance those
experiments and i appreciate that side
you know one of the other things that we
we get asked about right all the time is
as we increase as we increase the
the number of of let's say colors in a
in an experiment we're adding more and
more and more antibodies to it and and
we get to that point where
we're at the mercy in some ways of the
concentration of those reagents when
they're bought as single vial reagents
and
they have a in the human side right we
we still work
in
to a certain percentage of them still in
test size and not in math size
um you know i guess maybe just a a
question for you do you do you think
that
that all reagents and flow should should
be converted over to mass units like we
do in the mouse in the mouse field uh
especially for these high dimensional uh
you know experiments
do you mean micrograms or uh you know
yeah in a microgram uh format rather
than in the format of of test size or do
you not see the problem associated with
with keeping saturation and you know at
a at a specific level
well no saturation is important we
always titrate just to make sure we we
use such rating concentration because
um
so in in some cases we have we have a
lot of samples to to to stain and we
don't really count the cells so we don't
really know how many cells we're
staining so we just have to make sure we
are in a good range of of concentration
so we saturate all the receptors
um
ideally to have uh to have the mass i i
don't know
we don't really look
so to be honest i don't really look at
the data sheet when i get a reagent i
just go straight to titration and then
test
and then see what is the optimal
concentration so in the end we test
everything and
make sure that everything works
correctly
and if we change that volume we change
slot
we just have to make sure it performs
the same way as the one before
so yeah it's very important for
reproducibility yeah
yeah i think one of the
i appreciate that you know one of the
big questions that also comes out all
the time is you know with all the data
tools that are out there
you know how do you
how do we
how do we evaluate the accuracy of high
dimensional flow data
um
so i try to explain a little bit during
the webinar so there's many q iq steps
okay so it's uh
a simple work um i think some so for
example as as we have an rna
and then the body fermentation spills
through a number of different qc steps
flow cytometry uh doesn't
things are changing but it doesn't have
this this this level of
let's say control because
ideally as technologists you know you
get some cells you transform antibodies
in
and then you run through the floss i
don't know which is use small sequencer
that it's probably more difficult to use
to specialize the
technicians doing that
but but
but from
like let's start from the basics so
antibodies titration make sure your
antibodies validated correctly uh and
then you put together some antigens and
you have to make sure that they don't
interfere much with with each other or
if they do then you have to make sure
you can manage that interference
by by defining your panel correctly by
by by making sure you can cope with the
spreading error
and that's and that's then that's the
second level and then you run a complex
panel and maybe you do comparison with a
less complex panel just to make sure it
performs the same and then once you
run all your
experiments you have to make sure you
run today you run tomorrow you have
similar performance so machine
performance sustaining performance
and once you have done all that then
it's already quite a lot okay so
sample preparation and panel development
is very important
um and then with with the high
dimensional data then it's uh
then it's also a matter of optimization
in that case so in the very beginning we
were running these k n clustering
algorithms and so we had to go through
all the different caves
uh just to decide what is the correct
number of diff
of uh
the nearest neighbors
um
i don't think that is a definitive
answer so now we tend to run uh to
analyze the elbow plots to show you what
is the
optimal number of cluster per different
case
but in the very beginning we used to run
like a decay let's say 15 30 100 500 and
then analyze all the different heat maps
it was like a lot of work
uh just to make sure that they were bad
okay and then going back to the the to
the original data and and confirm
so um
this is explained
quite a bit in our nature problems it's
um
it's quite detailed in in that sense
but now it's been two years already so
there are a lot of new
so if you can find maybe tutorials from
other uh additional algorithms they're
probably uh
even more advanced
very good you know as you know one of
the things that i'm i'm sure you you saw
and were really involved with at nih
involved a lot of you know
determining the
the minimum number of cells like the
antigen specific responses you did to
the hiv peptides and all that work that
was done and and and we saw how many
cells that we had to obtain just to get
the accuracy of data
but today you know we're we're using so
many different antibodies and evaluating
so many different dimensions of biology
you know how do we
how do you evaluate the least number of
of events you need to get quality data
okay so again there's a very nice
comment from mario in cytometry about
ten times probably more than ten years
ago um it's called how many cells are
enough are you positive or something
like that
um
i think it poses it poses the problem so
obviously it depends on the frequency
of uh of the cells that you're looking
for
so if the cell is antigen specific you
might
want to use a lot of spells because
otherwise you won't be able to detect
um
that specific response
otherwise if the cell population is very
abundant then you don't have to run that
many cells we can easily do phenotyping
on few hundred cells from tumors
so obviously the robustness of all the
clusterings if you want to obtain a lot
of clusters then it's not
very robust but if you're looking for
major populations a few hundred cells is
fine if the distribution of your antigen
is abundant is abundant enough
uh so it's like uh
vaccinating a large population
right so you you vaccinate a thousand
you don't get five bags and they
especially the million then you get one
side effect in a million which is still
very low
just to bring it
to the today's uh
news so get vaccinated
or run a lot of sales if you have the
possibility yeah it's a it's a real it's
a real problem that's a lot of these
experiments that we have today
you know there's there's other questions
in here and there there's just many from
from so many directions but you know
when you when you sit down and you begin
to process data and to look with these
data tools that we have today
you know how do you how do you go
through the selection process of
determining
which one of the algorithms that you use
to analyze data
um
so we
this is something that some people do
but not many people do so uh again there
is like a new algorithm coming out every
week okay it's it's really overwhelming
it's a lot of stuff which is good
then you can test many of them
but at the same time you need to get
your answers uh in the end so i don't
think it's feasible to
to test a lot of things
so we we started working with with this
algorithm called phenograph a while ago
uh and and we we like it so we kept
moving that but for example i also
mentioned something from size so yvonne
uh
developed this this very nice algorithm
which is also
faster than than phenograph
uh but there's others you know they're
they're not the only ones um
we try to combine accuracy with speed
also some might be
very fast that's not very accurate or
they might be very accurate but not that
fast then if it takes day
to get the data back then
i don't think it's very feasible
so you do this because you want to speed
up
discovery so you have to find to find a
compromise in general you know even
though it might take a a few hours in
some cases but now we have for example
simone developed a python code that now
takes minutes instead of hours
so it's much faster
um but otherwise we run them like at
night so the computer just goes on and
we sleep so
that's good you know we just have just a
minute or so left here and
i i know it's it's certainly something
that many people are looking at today
and and ourselves internally
when even when we qc and look at it
at panels and try to understand them
as we get as we look at at biology and
we expand the numbers of specificities
and we define biology in so many
different ways today
we're finding that the repertoire of
normal biology is just really
really
you know complex and there's
receptors missing and and
and
not all people as we know are not the
same but
what are we what do we need to do as we
address a bio you know a disease and we
collectively look at lots of different
you know
samples but are we looking enough
normals to understand
really
the receptor proteome in in normals
before we
before we go through and just look at a
lot of diseases where we too see
these
these types of deletions and of speci of
certain specificities
or is it are we doing enough in in in
normal biology
i think we lost i think yeah i think we
lost i think we lost enrico on that last
question i actually really wanted to
hear that answer um
i i guess in closing you know i'd like
to
to say to everyone that we appreciate
very much um
we'll too try to get enrico's answer on
that last question because i think it's
a really important one for our field um
and i'll i'll turn it over to our
moderators to to close our session
and i too want to thank enrico and bob
for their time today and for their
important presentation and i also want
to thank labrits and our sponsor bd
biosciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone and stay safe bye-bye
thank you bye-bye
thanks enrico yeah